in one cross test the foundation thought
scp-682 the hard-to-destroy reptile
would bite off more than it could chew
with scp-807
a deadly plate from the last chance
diner this plate makes any food placed
on it extra delicious but also makes
them extra unhealthy so unhealthy that
people who eat its food tend to die of
massive heart attacks they use the plate
to transmute two scp-682 specials a mix
of 10 kilograms of rotten meat and
sharpened bone splinters 10 liters of
rancid mayonnaise one liter potassium
cyanide and one kilogram morphine
hydrochloride considered a five star
course for our pal
scp-682 and fed it to the beast at first
it seemed immobile perhaps the monster
had been bested but when d-classes
entered to check the creature's skin
ruptured in several areas ejecting
high-pressure jets of its own blood in
every direction killing them all the
reptile was completely fine afterward
and eagerly ate a third 682 special in
one cross test the hard to destroy
reptile scp-682 was made to face off
against
scp-689 the terrifying haunter in the
dark a statue that can induce death in
anyone who looks at it and then stops
paying attention the statue was placed
in 682's chamber and the lights were
turned off for five minutes when the
lights were turned back on 682 laid
motionless in a pile of dark gray goo
when a d-class was sent in to confirm
the kill 682 suddenly rose back up to
its feet and devoured him in an instant
two swift chomps with its razor-sharp
teeth and the d-class was history it
seems that 682 doesn't fit the same
definition of alive as us humans and as
a result was unaffected by the haunter
in the dark frighteningly 682 was also
smart enough to intuit 689's anomalous
ability and use this knowledge to play
dead and attempt escape it's the clash
of the titans
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
versus scp-096
the terrifying murderous shy guy but who
won this battle well it was kind of a
draw their battle lasted for 72 whole
hours and ended in a brutal stalemate
with scp-096 severely injured and
huddled in one corner of the room and
682 in the other missing 85 percent of
its original body mass the creatures
were both brought back to their chambers
with relative ease a fight like this can
never happen again because now whenever
096 is brought too close to 682 it turns
away shrieks and begins clawing at its
own face in one cross test
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile was
made to face off against
scp-1360
a giant aggressive mass of animal slurry
that envelops and digests everything it
touches before briefly taking on their
traits just over one thousand kilograms
of
scp-1361 was poured onto scp-682
and it successfully enveloped the
creature the problem was that it then
began taking on traits and a temperament
incredibly similar to scp-682
after developing legs jaws and other
physical features similar to the reptile
it broke out of containment and killed
17 members of staff after several failed
attempts to stop the creature with small
arms fire it was finally destroyed by
the aerial deployment of napalm 682
skeletal carcass was retrieved from
within and placed back in its chamber it
had regenerated back to perfect health
within a mere six hours we all have that
one friend we just can't take anywhere
with us without a little explanation and
a whole lot of embarrassment nobody
expected what would happen when the scp
foundation cross-tested scp-682 the
hard-to-destroy reptile with scp-082
a giant aggressive humanoid called
ferdinand the cannibal when they
presented ferdinand with a tissue sample
of 682 he said oh splendid my friend
lives when he entered the containment
chamber 682 immediately attempted to
flee from him despite fernand claiming
they were friends who went way back and
in fact 682 had once been his loyal
steed after extended fighting ferdinand
began to ride 682 and experience the
reptile found supremely humiliating once
zero a2 left the giant was delighted and
scp-682 said something about him that we
can't repeat if we want to keep
monetization on this video in one
particularly exciting cross test the
foundation set scp-682 the infamous hard
to destroy reptile against
scp-204 a cloud of deadly all-consuming
nanites bonded to a small child for the
purposes of protecting them as scp-682
naturally attacked the child the nanites
sprung into action forming the shape of
a huge warrior with an axe and shield
the battle was intense but amazingly
despite taking tremendous damage itself
the scp-204 warrior kicked the stuffing
out of scp-682
as is expected of scp-204 its nanites
began feeding on scp-682's immobilized
body but surprise surprise as cp-682
started regenerating faster than the
nanites could eat it it then began to
attack scp-202 once again the foundation
tranquilized both parties and hosed
scp-682 with hydrochloric acid before
returning them both to their chambers
all anomalies contained no children
harmed delegating a high priority task
to a person who only delivers a bare
minimum style of work ethic otherwise
will probably result in the task not
getting done the foundation tried to
snuff out scp-682 with the help of
scp-2599
formerly known as xena cho a woman of
korean descent who will carry out any
order you give her but only around
halfway that's why the foundation
ordered her to attack 682 until it was
200 dead so even if she only did her
task by halves it would still be one
hundred percent dead by all accounts she
was actually doing a pretty solid job
horrifically mutilating the creature to
the point of near death when it suddenly
yelled kill me you psycho organs do it
and that order seemingly confused her
seeing as only going halfway on killing
the creature was something she'd already
done she remained motionless in the test
chamber until she was physically removed
and later attempts to use her in 682's
termination were fruitless the
foundation once tried to kill scp-682
the hard to destroy reptile with scp-272
an old iron nail this anomalous nail can
kill its victims in a number of ways the
nail binds a victim's shadow to the
ground indirectly binding the victim
itself as well by doing so if the shadow
is displaced due to changes in light
source the victim is flung and contorted
in the same direction the shadow has
moved if the victim tries to destroy the
nail they will surely die after the
foundation intentionally made the lights
in 682's chambers strobe on and off from
various directions causing the reptile
to be mutilated by being hurled around
the room its body began producing an
extremely powerful light source
eliminating its own shadow and keeping
it safe the light was so bright that
when d-classes entered the chamber to
remove the nail despite wearing eye
protection they were afflicted with
permanent retinal damage and of course
in the end
scp-682 was just fine in one of the more
desperate attempts to kill scp-682 the
hard-to-destroy reptile the scp
foundation employed the use of scp-3802
a bottle of anti-baldness ointment known
as hair growth by dotto but not just any
hair if you apply this to the skin of an
adult they'll break out in huge painful
tumorous masses that turn into giant
flemish rabbits this anomalous chemical
was spritzed onto scp-682 by the
sprinklers causing the bees horrific
pain and massive unchecked tumor growth
as these tumors broke away and became
giant rabbits they tore off 40 of
scp-682 body mass however it didn't
stick as scp-682 ate the rabbits while
it was regenerating back to the drawing
board who would win the hard to destroy
reptile or 9.15 million kilograms of
bananas this is scp-682 versus scp-3521
when scp-682 was cross-tested with
scp-3521
a little yellow pill that makes bananas
manifest in the stomach of those who eat
them the foundation hoped to answer that
question 682 was tricked into eating the
pill by hiding it inside the body of a
dead cow which was then fed to the
monster as time passed an absurd number
of bananas began to manifest in and
around scp-682
filling its containment chamber and then
the entire facility however just when it
seems 682 was crushed under all that
potassium it began eating the bananas
faster than they could be produced and
because bananas are each slightly
naturally radioactive eating that many
gave scp-682 the ability to fire a
powerful radiation beam out of its mouth
until 3521's effects wore off the
craziest part this all occurred within a
10 minute period guess you could say
things when a little bananas there ready
for this one
scp-682 vs scp-835 is one of the most
horrifying scp-682 cross tests we have
logged to date that's right we have
paired the hard to destroy reptile with
the disgusting nightmare known as
scp-835 a giant carnivorous coral polyp
made from living human matter when
scp-835 was released the infectious
abomination pulled scp-682 into its
massive gullet dragging it down for a
slow and painful digestion surrounded by
the intense pressure and screaming human
faces of the beast's fleshy throat what
was eventually ejected was little more
than 682's skeleton however over time
the skeleton regenerated into a horrific
hybrid of scp-682 and
scp-835 covered in sticky tentacles
human faces spewing acid an infectious
spores that could turn others into
monsters it breached containment and
killed many the survivors had to be
terminated to avoid scp-835
contamination spreading further
scp-682 vs godzilla who would take home
the gold in the battle of these mighty
reptiles godzilla obviously has the
advantage in terms of his offensive
capabilities he's considerably larger
than scp-682 and has the incredible
power of his atomic breath capable of
taking down other huge monsters like
king jedora or other mutos however
scp-682 has its trump card insane
adaptability when faced with godzilla it
may adapt to imitate the monster's
atomic breath or begin to grow to epic
proportions to match it in size in the
end it's hard to know who would win but
a true stalemate seems incredibly likely
it's time for a clash of the titans
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
scp-106 the old man and scp-953 the
polymorphic humanoid this wasn't even a
foundation cross test just an organic
battle that occurred during a massive
containment breach
scp-953 and scp-106 entered 682's
containment chamber at which point they
all began staring at each other
preparing for an attack 106 began the
battle sinking into the floor and
grabbing 953 trying to pull her into his
pocket dimension she then grabbed 682
resulting in all three of them being
pulled into the pocket dimension they
all remained there for five hours before
returning heavily injured from their
fight 106 returned to his chamber 953
was recaptured by foundation personnel
and 682 regenerated its 67 percent body
mass loss all three have refused to
speak about the incident since the cross
test between scp-682 and scp-173 with
high precision blades was a complete
disaster organized by dr shenron the two
iconic monsters were brought into a test
chamber and the blades were deployed
cutting both of them into pieces two
d-classes were sent in when the vacuum
system failed and were killed by
scp-682's blobs of flesh and the newly
reformed
scp-173 at this point the battle began
and 173 attacked the different blobs of
682 flesh some blobs fought back while
others reformed into a smaller version
of 682 which stared at 173 just like in
the original test a sniper shut out the
eyes of this smaller 682 leading 173 to
snap its neck it then regenerated and
stared at 173 for 17 hours before the
test was finally ended when 173 was
taken back to its cell there was a power
failure in the hallway leading to a
site-wide containment breach and many
deaths as cp 682 versus the gate
guardian can the giant warrior with a
sword hotter than the sun finally kill
the hard-to-destroy reptile when scp-682
was brought in to hopefully meet its
ultimate destruction at the gate the
guardian guards it quipped is this meant
to be the garden
this is not the garden the garden is far
west of here when the gate guardian
struck 682 it was grievously wounded
with only a single leg left as it
regenerated it snarled at the gate
guardians saying die you command me to
die oh wouldn't we all like that but
this is my curse for suggesting the
fruit it struck again and before passing
out from its injuries 682 said
this is not the garden and you are not
urial pretender
you